[Music]
our bodies are constantly experiencing
changes from the external environment
whether it's changing seasons or the
variety of food we eat despite these
changes our biological systems are able
to function normally because of
something called homeostasis
through homeostasis our bodies achieve
optimal internal conditions to maintain
biological stability which is measured
in a certain numerical range around a
set point
a simple way to think about a set point
is how we use a thermostat to maintain
house temperature
once you set the temperature the system
monitors when it gets too cold and turns
the furnace on to heat the house
when the furnace heats the house to the
desired temperature your set point or
above the furnace shuts off to cool the
house back down
this is a constant back and forth
process to ensure the desired
temperature is always maintained but how
does this process work in the body
let's take a closer look
our biological systems use processes
known as feedback to help maintain ideal
internal conditions there are two main
types positive feedback and negative
feedback positive feedback moves
biological systems away from the set
point and negative feedback brings them
back to it
now let's look at positive and negative
feedback in action within our bodies the
birth of a child is primarily controlled
by positive feedback the brain releases
the oxytocin hormone at the start of
Labor which causes muscles in the uterus
to contract in waves these contractions
trigger the brain to produce even more
oxytocin which leads to even more
contractions helping to push the baby
out of the uterus and this process
continues until the baby is delivered
what about negative feedback loops
negative feedback keeps our bodily
processes near the set point one example
is blood sugar maintenance when we eat
our blood sugar levels rise but
prolonged high blood sugar levels can
lead to serious health problems
a molecule called insulin is released in
response to increased blood sugar which
helps sugar molecules enter cells to be
used for energy and simultaneously
lowers levels in the blood back to the
set point
but that's not all some forms of
negative feedback can actually
anticipate changes in a biological
system because simply turning certain
biological processes on or off isn't
enough to effectively maintain the set
point so our bodies have come up with a
few additional clever tricks for example
a negative feed forward system
here the body is able to anticipate When
A change is about to take place and make
adjustments in advance to avoid large
imbalances
a biological example is maintenance of
core body temperature internal organs
like the heart and brain are extremely
sensitive to small temperature changes
our skin however is less sensitive to
environmental changes so any temperature
adjustments detected through our skin
will signal to the brain to take
preventative measures like redirecting
blood flow to internal organs and
shivering to help maintain core body
temperature
if our body only used on off negative
feedback then our core body temperature
would reach dangerous levels before the
body was able to fix it
but sometimes feedback loops don't work
properly and cause health problems
congestive heart failure for example
occurs when a positive feedback loop
goes awry here heart blockages lead to
abnormal blood pressure which the
nervous system detects and attempts to
correct by sending signals to the heart
to pump harder
this leads to more heart damage which
further disrupts blood pressure and so
on
as you can see homeostasis is essential
to our overall health but actually all
systems like cars and computers use
these similar mechanisms to function
normally so the governing principles of
homeostasis ensures that not only we but
also the world around us is always in
balance